[music]
This is my city, an
industrial city in the middle of a forest in the east of
Ukraine, a city of comfortable quarters and
wide, spacious avenues, a city on the
sand where there was never any mud and
about which the locals often said,
check it.
from scratch, they built a factory for the
manufacture of bricks, and then from this brick they
built the city itself, this is Severodonetsk, a
city of highly educated people, scientists,
cybernetics and chemists, a city where
children first learned what ammonia,
urea and formalin are, not in chemistry lessons
in middle classes, but from everyday conversations and
walking around the neighborhoods  we learned to count to
86 and to distinguish parallels from
perpendiculars, a city in which it was difficult to
get lost among typical houses, because
wherever you looked, there were gray landmarks painted on gray walls,
this is Sever, a city with its own
views on naming, even when I
just went to the bazaar on Sunday to buy
potatoes, I went  to success And
everyone knows where the best pastries are in Vodol  to pick buns
and classics to the favorite
lake with the gentle local name Chistukha,
to start eating buns even more expensive and
share with the pigeons that chase
after them, nodding in time to the songs of
Mendeleev
's band.  of the regional center and did not die
without nitrogen, as he was prophesied, the city in
which the immigrants from the occupied [ __ ] of the
Luhansk region started life from scratch and to
which they felt the chemistry and called it a new
home, but one day in February in a
green place next to a gray zone,
black days came in the city on the sand
with  mud appeared and people who were used to
open spaces had to learn to live in cramped,
dark basements while the occupiers
destroyed the city to nothing and tried to
poison and kill all living things, but thanks
to the nitrogen basements we were saved.
This is Severodonetsk.
for industrial cities
undergauddni rave abandoned high-rise buildings and
atypical fe  Stival of thoughts And now there is
only one thought left, how are you
missing her North Donets routine, we
know that the time will come and the Armed Forces of Ukraine will clean
Verodonetsk of this mud, the
city will return to people, and Aquarius will return to
Palianitsa, and with it, the
enthusiasm will return to rebuild the city from scratch
And then on one of our  Maidans of the
Cathedral Peace or Victory finally
figure out the names together and celebrate every
routine day at home This is my city, this is
Severodonetsk and this is
[music]
Ukraine